Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube Đại Sir Bài số 2
nhập liệu và làm quen với các thành phần
của Excel trước khi bắt đầu vào bài học
thứ hai thì mình sẽ cùng giải hai cái
câu hỏi của bài học số 1 nhá câu thứ
nhất là 2 cái thao tác lưu file xếp và
cfs giống và khác nhau như thế nào thì
đầu tiên ý là giống nhau như thế nào thì
nó giống nhau là diện khi các bạn mở
file lên nó chưa có tên tên mặc định thì
để đặt tên cho nó thì có bạn có thể dùng
xếp hoặc xếp em đều được thì như vậy cái
sếp và sếp s giống nhau và việc nó giống
nhau ở cái lúc mà đặt tên pha thì khi mà
các bạn đặt tên file thì biết xếp và CF
là giống nhau đấy còn khác nhau là gì ạ
Khi mà nó có tên file rồi đấy thì nó hai
cái thủ tục lại hoàn toàn khác nhau xếp
Tức là mình sẽ cập nhật cái trạng thái
gần nhất còn cái phép là mình sẽ tạo ra
một cái file mới Đấy đấy là cái khác
nhau nhất là khi có tên rồi ạ thì cái xô
ý là khác nhau Ok sang câu hỏi số 2 là
diện khi mình nhập ngày tháng năm trong
Excel Vậy thì mình có thể đổi sang cái
mặc định là nhập ngày trước rồi Đến
tháng Đến 520 thì câu trả lời là hoàn
toàn có thể nhá chị để đổi được cái này
thì các bạn làm như sau nhé Thì liệu các
bạn sẽ thích bằng cách xác này các bạn
rõ con số alen đi còn tích vào đây đây
sau đó bạn sẽ vào đâu ạ thì trong cái
phần view bye nơi này các bạn sẽ thích
vào đây các bạn sẽ chọn rồi category đấy
Sau đó họ diện tích và cải thiện các bạn
sẽ thích ngồi đây lại trên deadtime hoặc
là number format các bạn thích ở đây nhá
Đấy thì bạn tích vào cái thẻ format ở
đây nhá thì mặc định khi các bạn cài Win
hoặc là người khác cài Win cho các bạn
đấy thì người ta hay chọn cái format ở
đây là cái kiểu anh nhưng mà anh nghĩ
thì bây giờ mình xin đổi sang cái kiểu
Việt Nam nữa các bạn thích ở đó lấy toàn
sẽ nằm xuống dưới các bạn chọn Việt Nam
Việt Nam là chữ v thì thường thường nó
sẽ nằm ở cuối cùng lại các bạn sẽ kéo
xuống cuối cùng các bạn chọn này Các bạn
nhìn chữ v Việt Nam
Ừ đấy thì khi các bạn chọn Việt Nam thì
bạn thấy cho cái soát biết này nó sẽ
chuyển sang điện biết rồi mà nặng kia để
gọi xem bấm offline hãy gọi sếp bấm ok
Bây giờ còn Khởi động Excel lên nhá các
bạn vào start này còn gọi Excel enter
này sao bạn tiếp tục vào đây ví dụ mình
kéo rộng cái cục đê này ra nhé để mình
nhập ngày tháng rồi gọi sẽ nhật ví dụ là
ngày mai nhựa ngày 25 tháng 2 năm bao
nhiêu 2020 Con ăn cơm đói gọn thế cho
thì như vậy Lúc này các bạn sẽ nhập nhập
ngày trước bà tháng sau và năm thì nó
mới đúng nhá Còn nếu như bạn Nhập tháng
trước này ví dụ 02 này ngày bao nhiêu 25
nếu như bạn Nhập tháng trước nhé 2020
thì nó sẽ không đúng Tại vì gì ạ Nó sẽ
hiểu là cái kiểu này là cái kiểu Tech
lại để cho nên các bạn hết sức lưu ý cho
mình nhé các bạn chú ý nhá mặc định
trong Excel Vậy thì nếu như mà kiểu tết
thì khi các bạn Nhập vào thì nó sẽ nằm ở
bên trái để bọn nó cho nó sẽ nằm ở góc
trái này còn cái kiểu ngày tháng
Ừ hai cái kiểu số thì nó sẽ nằm ở sát
bên phải ví dụ các bạn Nhập số 8 vào đây
thì bạn thấy chứ cái số 8 nó sẽ làm sao
để bên phải để cho nên khi có nhập ngày
tháng 2 nhập số mà nó làm ở bên trái thì
nó không phải là số đông Các bạn nhìn đi
thì bạn tưởng là số 2 ngày tháng nhưng
mà thực chất nó không phải bảo nó là
kiểu tích nhá Nó là số vào ngày tháng
khi mà nó làm ở bên phải đây là cái lưu
ý cho mình nhé bây giờ để đổi lại gì em
để đổi lại cái ngày tháng 5 nhá Mà mình
muốn nhập tháng trước ngày sau nhá thì
các bạn lại thích vào thì các bạn vào
con chó operon thôi phải có bạn chọn
trên bếp xanh hoặc number format đấy
Thực ra thì mình khuyên các bạn nên
chuyển về cái anh Mỹ tại vì ngoài cái
việc nhập ngày tháng này nó rất là nhiều
cái thứ nó liên quan lại thì mình thì
mình hay dùng cái chuẩn của anh mỹ thì
nó phù hợp hơn các tài liệu hướng dẫn nó
cũng chuẩn hơn nhé để họ sẽ nhìn cái
English và các bạn sẽ chọn để English
của United đây thoại quá sẽ chuyển về
cái này đấy khi con chọn cái nick này
nhưng lại tiết Đó thấy chưa Lúc này lại
gì
Vì sao nói Đến Tết Rồi đến Yên các bạn
có thể bấm offlife các bạn bằng Ok còn
đóng vai con cho kara này nữa đấy cận
thế chứ Khi mà các bạn đổi thế Các bạn
thấy là cái này nó lại đổi về diện tháng
trước ngày sau đấy và nó lại nằm bên
phải bây giờ các bạn Nhập lại nhé ví dụ
mình nhập không hai này này hay nhau năm
2020 lúc vừa xong rồi mình chọn tháng
trước sau đến ngày 5 có các em Thơ đấy
còn thấy lúc này nó đã nằm ở bên bên
phải rồi cho nên cái kiểu ngày tháng nay
là đúng nhá Đây Ok mình trên đó cái file
đấy ạ để cậu chứ nhắn Nếu như các bạn
bấm Đôn xếp Vậy thì con sẽ đóng cái file
này lại mà không lưu Còn nếu như con bấm
cancel thì mình sẽ không đóng cái file
này ạ Đấy Ok mình đóng Mình sẽ đồ Sếp
tôi là mình sẽ không lưu file là tại
mình sẽ đóng lại như vậy mình đã trả lời
xong các bạn cái bài số 1 nhé Ok mình sẽ
vào cái bài học số 2 nhé các bạn chú ý
các bạn sẽ tải cái file này về nhé các
bạn sẽ tải cái folder của bài học số 2
về sau đó các bạn phải đến xanh nhé Còn
nếu như bạn nào mà chưa biết cách tải
các bạn sẽ vào cái bài mở đầu mình đã
hướng dẫn chi tiết cách tải file thực
hành về rồi nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ kết thúc
rồi đó đấy trong cái bài thứ hai này
mình sẽ yêu cầu các bạn được trẻ con sẽ
nhập một cái bảng như thế này mình sẽ
làm ví dụ luôn cho các bạn thì sau đó
mình sẽ giới thiệu cho các bạn các cái
thành phần của Excel nhá lại mình sẽ
đóng cái file này lại Bây giờ mình sẽ
khởi động Excel nhé các bạn thì các bạn
nhấn bật xác là gọi Excel lên để gọn
tích vào đây mình sẽ tạo một cái tay
trắng nhá Ok Bây giờ các bạn cứ thích
vào cái chữ in sướng này trước đi nha
các bạn tích của Isaac Các bạn sẽ thích
vào cái picture các bạn sẽ chọn Repair
lại các bạn sẽ trỏ đến cái thư mục mà
chứa cái ảnh kia đúng không Lúc đấy Mình
lưu ở desktop là folds Excel cơ bản đến
nâng cao có sự tích vào cái bài số 2 là
do họ rất thích vào cái ảnh thời khóa
biểu này là như vậy mình đã chèn cái ảnh
vào đây những rồi nhé mình xem cái ảnh
để mình hướng dẫn thực hành các bạn dễ
hiểu này
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ làm một cái bảng mà
giống hệt cái file ảnh để cho các bạn
xem nhé đầu tiên các bạn chú ý này ở đây
là gì ạ Cái ở đây là cái cột b này hành
số 2 mình sẽ làm với nhịp thời gian là
buổi đúng không cô c Đây là Tiết đúng
không Đấy cái Obi hai này mình sẽ làm
sau nhé mình sẽ là mấy oc2 chất là tiết
Nha chọn thể tích và Note 2 là mình sẽ
ghi là vị tiết để gọi em các bạn ấy mua
cho sao phải là tiếp theo mình sẽ là thứ
hai này cho m bây giờ còn rất tích bằng
ô thứ 2 sau đó bạn hiện các bạn giữ
chuột trái vào góc dưới ở bên phải này
khi nó có hiện cái dấu cộng nhỏ thì bạn
giữ được trái gọn kéo sang đây để đến
thứ 6 thôi nhá cái gọi bỏ chạy ra đấy
tôi sẽ mặc định điện nó sẽ biển thứ hai
thứ ba thứ tư thứ năm thứ sáu giờ các
bạn đúng không ở đây là ghi chúng không
đại thì như vậy mình đã tạo xong bây giờ
tiếp theo là gì ạ Cái cột C3 là tiết một
đúng không c3 Đây là các bạn sẽ ghi diện
tiết một cái gọi
E là diện 7:30 đúng không 7 giờ hai chấm
này 30 thấy đoạn cách ra đến việc đến 8
giờ 15 cậu sẽ đóng ngoặc đơn lặng lẽ bây
giờ con sẽ tích Đúc vào cái cột C này
dọn di chuyển giữa của C và 1B nhá còn
thích đút vào đây nó sẽ mở rộng các cột
C lại ra hoa các bạn giữ được trái kéo
rộng ra cũng được lại tiếp theo thứ hai
cái bống nha Còn giữ đây còn kéo này
thoại các bạn cứ kéo rộng ra đi để lát
nữa mình sẽ đổi tên Bây giờ chọn sẽ
thích đút vào Cái ô này để bạn sửa nha
Đấy ví dụ đây là tiết hay này Đấy thiết
hai từ bao nhiêu ạ 8:30 đúng không đến
diện đến 9 giờ 15 lại cậu sẽ tích vào
đây đây là kết 3A
chi tiết 3 thực hiện từ 9 giờ 30 đến 9
giờ 10 đến 10 giờ 15 phút lại gọi thích
đút vào đây tiết 4 này từ bao nhiêu
10:30
cho đến 10 giờ 15 mình có 15 phút ra
chơi mà ví dụ thế nhá hoặc các bạn em tư
này đây tiết 1 của buổi chiều đúng không
Buổi chiều là ví dụ ở đây là gì buổi
chiều quy định là 13:30 đó 13 giờ 30 đến
14 giờ 15 enter này tiếp theo là tiết
hay để 14:30 đúng không đến bao nhiêu
15:15 để tọa Thích đua vào đây tiết 3 là
gì 15 giờ
từ 30 đến bao nhiêu 16 giờ bạn thích
nước vào đây Mình rất thích vào đây mình
Xoay Số 8 đi Rồi enter đây là hết bốn
này từ bao nhiêu ạ 16 giờ 30 đến 17 giờ
15 phút lại các bạn cứ làm đi nhé cái
sau mình làm trước để chọn sau đó mình
giải thích cho bạn dễ hiểu thôi tiếp
theo là diện từ cái Obi ba đến B6 này
đây thì bạn sẽ model từ B3 đến 16 các
bạn giữ chuột trái vào ngăn kéo xuống
nhá Để sau đó bạn sẽ vào thích vào cái
chữ hôm rồi này các bạn tích vào cái chữ
mượt en centos đấy thì như vậy là gì 4U
này sẽ gồm có một Đúng không các bạn sẽ
tích luôn vào đây họ sẽ gõ là gìánh sáng
cho enter thì tương tự các bạn sẽ
bodil40 ôn này các bạn vào cái chữ hôm
này các bạn thích làm ướt em center ở
đây Ở đây còn thích đút vào đây con sẽ
gõ thì chiều
Con gái bây giờ bạn sẽ giữ cho chai các
Bôi đen hay ô này Tại sao đó bạn vào thẻ
hôm mình sẽ mình sẽ cắn giữa đấy đấy Các
bạn nhìn nó đẹp hơn đúng không Bây giờ
cái cột bên này mình sẽ kéo rộng ra nhé
Để phạm cái gạch ngang này thì mình lại
như thế nào có bạn xinh nháy chuột phải
vào Cái ô này để họ sẽ chọn format Cell
ư
Khi mình kéo ra đây các bạn sẽ thích vào
cái phần Border à
ở lại các bạn sẽ nhìn ở bên dưới này bên
phải đây này có cái cái kéo này còn
thích rồi đấy bạn sẽ bấm ok thì cần thấy
như vậy có 1 cái gạch chéo vào giữa cái
cột bên này rồi đó Oh B2 là rồi nó còn
kéo rộng ra thì cậu sẽ tích lũy vào đây
mình sẽ ghi là diện thời gian đúng không
các bạn giữa ăn và các bạn bấm enter
nhất các bạn giữ phím an các bạn bộ
Master ở đây là gì buổi đấy sau đó bọn
tích chuột nên trước cái chữ thời gian
này Con bấm vô cách để gọi sếp bấm vô
cách để cái chữ ra này nó sát với góc
bên phải lại đây sau đó bấm enter đấy
còn thấy cho như vậy là cái chút thời
gian ở sát bên này mà cái chữ buổi ở
dưới này rất là hay bây giờ còn giữ chữa
cháy quận Portland nhá từ cái B2 đến
diện đến
u&i 10 đây này để họ xem vào cái thẻ hôm
phải ta sẽ vào cái dấu tam giác ở đây
này các bạn chọn ô ô được à
Vì vậy bây giờ mình sẽ Bôi đen để mình
sẽ Bôi đen các cái tiêu đề đây nhá Hay
cả rất thích vào đây là màu vàng luôn
các bạn sẽ tích vào đây còn chọn màu
vàng này chữ màu đỏ đúng không có tích ở
đây họ sẽ chọn cái màu đỏ này Đấy và có
thích bằng chữ bên này để tô đậm này rồi
Ok như vậy là giống rồi đúng không Bây
giờ tôi sẽ cập nhật các môn học nhá ở
đây ví dụ thứ hai là toán này gọi hai
chấm là gì cô A là đây là địa lý này hay
chấm thầy B khóa này hay chấm OC và văn
hai chấm liệng thầy đê các bạn tích vào
giữa của Xêkô D ngoãn thích lúc này thì
như vậy mình đã nhập xong cái mẫu về
thời khóa biểu đây rồi nhá tương tự các
bạn có thể nhập cho thứ ba thứ tư thứ
năm thứ sáu và các cái buổi chiều nhá ở
đây mình làm mẫu như thế này thôi đấy Ok
về các bạn có thể nhấn chuột phải vào
cái quay trở lại các bạn cắt nó đi
Ừ thế là mình sẽ xóa ảnh đấy đi không
còn cái ảnh nữa đúng không Để như vậy
mình đã xong cái thời khóa biểu này Bây
giờ mình sẽ đặt tên file này nha các bạn
vào thì file các bạn sắp xếp này thì
mình làm thì tốt nhất mình nhập vai đúng
không đấy còn thấy trước khi gọi là tên
file nhá thì gọi thích một xét thì nó
mặc định nó cũng nhớ đến cfs Tức là mình
đặt tên file thì cái sếp vff đều là
giống nhau đúng không Lại Mình sẽ lưu
vào đây cậu xem brow này vì giận rosado
mình sẽ vào desktop mà tôi Seo cơ bản
đến nâng cao đúng không Mình là bài số 2
Đấy ví dụ bây giờ ạ nhập liệu nghị Đây
là thời khóa biểu đại mình đang đặt tên
file là nhập liệu thời khóa biểu rồi
đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ giới thiệu
cho các bạn các các thành phần của cái
phái xe này nhá Đây là ca sĩ Thì bạn
biết rồi đúng không đầu tiên là diện
trên cái thanh này gọi là pho L3 đây khi
bạn chó đây này thì nó là format Nếu như
các Cái ô này mà là tách thì nó sẽ hết ở
đây là cách Còn nếu như ở cổ đây mà công
thức Nhã ví dụ bạn bằng này năm
khi cộng 14 hạn thế nhá Đấy thì nó ra
kết quả là trí đúng không khi bạn tích
vào cái ô số 9 đây này thì trên cái
Thanh pho mua 3 nó sẽ hiện ở huyện công
thức chứ không phải là hiện kết quả nhá
đấy Còn nếu như cái ô là tách thì nó sẽ
hiện tách còn là công thức thì cái Phong
roba này nó sẽ công thức còn bên trái
đây này là cái lên bóp thì mình đã giải
thích ở cái video trước rồi đúng không
thấy mỗi một ơi ở đây thì nó sẽ trong
cái game móc lại nó sẽ hiển thị là diện
nó ở cột bao nhiêu và hàng bao nhiêu vậy
Còn nếu như chọn lựa chọn một vùng thì
bạn có thể đặt tên cho nó nhắc tên cái
vùng của các bạn tiếp theo mình sẽ giới
thiệu với các bạn về cái thẻ đấy Cái cái
thẻ là gia vị đầu tiên là cái kẹp file
nhá để gọi Stick wi-fi này thì trong cái
thẻ file đó sẽ có cái thông tin gì đầu
tiên là lưu new tức là các bạn sẽ tạo
một cái file mới đây ví dụ Các bạn thích
và lưu này khi gọi tích còn lưu thì nó
sẽ có một số tùy chọn luôn Miu Lê là cái
Blanc Facebook và một số cái hướng dẫn
khác nhé Đây là một số các em biết nhé
Cái template này Thực ra nó khá là những
dụng Nếu như các bạn định nào Cái gì đấy
ví dụ các bạn
Ừ mai mà có lịch chẳng hạn nhất thì đoạn
lên tick chọn các em viết này thì nó sẽ
có rất nhiều cái tem viết về lịch cho
bạn chọn lấy ví dụ Họ thích là kem đời
này nhá thì nó sẽ có rất là nhựa for này
có thích ở đây nó sẽ có các cái mẫu
Tablet khác nhau nếu như con ăn thích
tạo các em viết nào thì gọi chọn nơi cái
vừa xong mình cũng thấy khá là đẹp nữa
đấy các bạn thích cái tem viết này các
bạn sẽ chọn cái clip nhá thì trong cái
phần này thì thông thường mình rất thích
ở đây để mình sẽ tạo các file mới đây
mình thích mở ra đấy là mình sẽ tạo một
cái file mới Bây giờ mình sẽ bóng lại
quay lại cái kẹp phanh á thì cái Open
thì mình đã giải thích trước lấy rồi
đúng không Open để các bạn mở một cái
file cái info này là cái thông tin về
cái file này của mình để đây Các bạn
thấy một số thông tin này à
ở đây cái sếp và sếp em thì mình đã nói
rồi đúng không xếp là mình sẽ lưu với
trạng thái gần nhất CF là mình sẽ tạo
một cái file mới giống đẹp này capron là
để mình yên nhá mình in với tài liệu của
mình ra cái xe là export với cả public
thì mình rất ít sử dụng trong các phạm
vi của cái khóa học này mình sẽ không
giới thiệu ba cái phần này cái close để
mình đóng cái file này ạ để các bạn
thích mà nho để các bạn có thể vào
option này quá thay đổi một số cái gì
chọn nhá Đây là cách kẹp phanh bây giờ
có bạn sự tích mà cái mũi tên này để
mình quay lại cái file Excel Tiếp theo
là cái thẻ hôm nhá thì còn chú ý nhất ở
mỗi cái thẻ khi đoạn tích vào cái thẻ
đây này nó gọi là thẻ này Hôm này Yên
Sơn này Miss leo này đây khi có ăn tích
bằng cái thẻ thì ở dưới là các cái nhóm
nhóm chức năng của các thẻ đấy ví dụ cái
thẻ hôm này thì cái kèo hôm nó có các
nhóm chức năng gì ạ Cái clip bóc này
nhóm chức năng của Phone này like cho
mình 5 mờ spa đấy thì trong các nhóm này
thì nó lại có các cái chức năng cụ thể ở
đây
Ừ thì music tìm hiểu qua một số các chức
năng á thì trong phạm vi này nó rất là
dài thì mình sẽ không thể tìm hiểu hết
thì trong các video tiếp theo thì mình
vừa làm vừa hướng dẫn các bạn sử dụng
các cái thành phần trong cái cái thẻ này
nhá các bạn chỉ cần hiểu đơn giản đây là
các cái thẻ điều khiển và xử lý hay là
thao tác với cây dữ liệu của các bạn nhá
lại đầu tiên là cái ví dụ cái thẻ phone
nhá Lúc nãy mình đã giải thích rồi chẳng
hạn thế có thể tô đậm này nếu như bạn
muốn tô đậm nhiều ô Ví dụ mình muốn tôi
động 2 ôn này Các Model trước này các
bạn tích vào cái chữ B đấy Bạn thấy chứ
nó sẽ mua rượu này còn tất cả với chữ y
là in nghiêng đúng không còn tĩnh và cái
chữ mà dưới đây này entried thì là dị nó
sẽ gạch chân ở dưới này Đấy nếu cho các
bạn bỏ chọn thì gọn lại tinh một lần nữa
bỏ một lần nữa thì nó sẽ thích bỏ một
lần nữa này nó sẽ thích đấy Ở đây là cái
thẻ phone nhá các iPhone rồi Diện Nó sẽ
thay đổi cái kiểu phông chữ đầy ví dụ
các bạn bodil40 ô này nhá sau đó bạn vào
cái thẻ Phone này còn tích và cái phone
này Gọi thế cho thì
bài gọi Bôi đen này nó sẽ hiện iPhone
mẫu này gọi nhìn này nếu như bạn thấy
phone nào mà cái phong ấy nhiều bạn gọi
là Phong mình cứ có thể dùng phone không
nhá Đợi thì bạn sẽ chọn cái phong nào mà
có thích này đây ví dụ mình chọn nó
không Này nhá đã cảm thấy chứ Đây là
quan Chọn phông chữ này còn đây là cỡ
chữ đây đây ví dụ Lúc nãy mình bôi 4 cái
ô tiêu đề này rồi đúng từ thứ tư đến cái
ghi chú này nếu các bạn có thể thay đổi
các khối chữ thăm nhau lại hoặc các bạn
có thể nhập trực tiếp nhé Nếu như mình
thích 13 nhà thì gọn gõ 13 của đây các
em từ đấy thì cái phông chữ này nó sẽ là
13 hoặc là gì đấy 16 thì tùy các bạn Các
bạn có thể thay đổi phông chữ thì mặc
định nó là 11 đúng không tiếp theo ở đây
là mình sẽ tô màu nhé mình sẽ tô màu cho
cái ô đây ví dụ cái tiết này mình bộ này
còn tích vào cái tam giác ở đây để các
bạn chọn màu nhá lại Tùy các bạn ví dụ
mình chọn cái màu xanh nhà thấy đi đấy
thì những cái ôm trọn nó có màu xanh
nhạt đúng không ạ Đây là cái kiểu màu
chữ ví dụ ở đây mình sẽ hiện
Xin chào các bạn sẽ tích ở đây nó sẽ có
nhiều bên màu chữ cho bạn chọn Ví dụ
mình chọn màu tím đi lấy bạn thấy thì
những cái chữ này nó sẽ màu tím Tiếp
theo là cái applied mừng nhá Cái ơn
reitman đây ví dụ như cái ô này mình sẽ
cắm giữa lên cái giữ ở đây là gì nó sẽ ở
giữa Cái ô này nó sẽ coi như đây có
thích ở đây lại còn thấy nó sẽ dịch niên
giữa đây có cái còn cái căn giữa này nó
sẽ căn giữa nó sẽ nhảy vào đây này các
bạn sẽ ăn giữa đây Đấy nó sẽ nhảy vào
đây Thông thường thì cái tiêu đề mình
thay mô đen và mình sẽ chọn căn giữa ở
đây và cắt dựa trên này thích ở đây là
căn trái Còn đây là gì Các bạn sẽ Xoay
cái chữ này Nếu được các bạn tích vào
đây nó sẽ xoay 45 độ này còn thấy cho ạ
sự tích ở đây là giả muốn nợ thuê các
bạn Các bạn thích bao nhiêu thì bạn chọn
cái hòa các bạn thích và cái format Cell
online đây các bạn có thể nhập độ trực
tiếp vào đây để thông thường của mình
thì mình sẽ để nhanh như thế này thì nó
là không độ để còn còn thích bao nhiêu
đội được ăn nhập với Đây nhá lại sang
ngang hay dọc thông thường mình sẽ không
độ là làm nhanh gọn bằng Ok lại thì nó
sẽ quay về nha Đây là một số các thuộc
tính nhá Đây là cái kiểu đô la là ví dụ
mình sẽ nhập họ thích và cái số 9 cho
con thích vào chữ Donal này thì nó sẽ
hiểu là cái chữ kiểu tiền tệ của Mỹ là
phần trăm thì nó sẽ chuyển được chín
trăm phần trăm đúng không Ví dụ mình
nhập vào 0.9 ở đây nhá Còn tích vào đây
Nếu như các tích phần trăm thì nó sẽ ra
là 90 phần trăm cái dấu phẩy là diện nó
sẽ hiển thị với số thập phân này bao
nhiêu số thập phân sau số nguyên không ạ
Đấy ở đây là sẽ tăng giảm với số thập
phân để co giãn đây là dạng số thập phân
là đây là tăng số thập phân này thì
tương tự nha một số các chức năng khác
thì mình sẽ giới thiệu
a Tiếp theo là cái thẻ Insert Insert Tức
là mình chèn nhá Thì lúc nãy mình đã
giới thiệu các bạn là mình chảnh rồi lúc
đấy mình tràng cái phát ảnh vừa xong
hoặc là các bạn có thể chèn các cái xếp
ở đây mình sẽ chèn các hình dạng và mong
muốn mẹ chọn giữa trái vọng kéo là đấy
nó chèn hình dạng nhá đó các bạn thay
đổi style cho nó Đấy là chè thành dạng
này cạnh các bạn lại vào lại Insert hoặc
các bạn có thể vẽ biểu đồ nhá Đấy thì
sau này thì trong các bài giảng mình sẽ
hướng dẫn chi tiết cho các bạn là các
cái thẻ Insert mình dùng như thế nào
hoặc các bạn có thể chèn các biểu tượng
tách này Quốc app này Ví dụ mình gõ cái
chữ nghệ thuật đấy đi nói ví dụ là cái
xem đây là các cái wordart các bạn có
thể xoay nhá Xoay ngang xoay dọc Tùy cậu
ạ Thế còn lại và lại sợ đi Các bạn có
thể chèn cái simple Tức là mình có thể
che những cái biểu tượng Đặc biệt này
simple lại có những cái kiểu đặc biệt ở
đây cái phần phone đấy Bạn sẽ chọn vì
khi chọn chọn cái kiểu gì thì bạn chọn
vào đây ví dụ cái kiểu Linh để nhiều ký
tự đặc biệt đây là like thứ gì con
Insert đấy Con bấm Grow con đấy chứ cái
biểu tượng hai ngón tay rô này các bạn
có thể đổi phong này to lên ví dụ mình
cho là 30 đi đấy bạn thấy cho mình lại
quay lại cái resort nhá cái son này cũng
khá nhiều với hai nữa Tiếp theo là cái
thẻ business hours được kết nối giao này
nó sẽ là những kiểu nó sẽ hiển thị dâm
Tức là mình sẽ hiển thiệu cái nền của
cái file này và dễ cái kết Sắp tới là
mình sẽ như kiểu là mình thiết lập các
trang in nữa đấy ví dụ đây nhá cái trang
của mình mặc định nó là triệu đúng rồi
Các bạn thích và nó sẽ là cái chiều
ngang lại mình chọn là chiều dọc cái này
thì nó liên quan đến y Tấn này cái sai
này này là mình sẽ chờ cái kích cỡ của
cái file này đúng ạ Đây nó có cái kích
cỡ ví dụ giấy A4 A3 hay ăn năm thì đấy
thì tùy các bạn nhé
đ.d cách pin LG Tức là mình sẽ lựa chọn
vùng in đây ví dụ mình muốn đi vùng này
thôi thì các bạn sẽ hôn em cái vùng này
và các bạn sẽ diện Premier League còn
xét nhé Đây thì lúc này nó chỉ in cái
vùng mà các bạn chọn thôi Cái backgroud
các bạn có thể thay đổi cái hình nền của
wifi này đây ví dụ mình sẽ Việt vì sự
Brown Mình sẽ chọn cái hình nền bất kỳ
Ví dụ mình chọn cái file vừa xong làm
cái hình nền cho con Insert này Đấy cái
ảnh này vừa xong nó sẽ thành hình nền
đấy còn thấy mình có thể mini cái mạnh
rau đi cái tên em này cũng khá là nhiều
cái hay đây ví dụ cái chữ này Nó nằm nó
đè lên cái bát rồi mình nha Bây giờ mình
muốn cái chữ để nó nằm dưới cái bát tầm
đấy thì qua sự tích vào cái chữ đây này
các bạn sẽ chọn đấy ạ santu password này
đấy còn được chứ Đây mình sẽ chọn với
forward thì nó lại chèn lên đấy Còn cái
Online vườn là gì Ví dụ mình rất tạo
nhiều cái các bạn Insert này các bạn sẽ
Chèn nhiều cái hình dạng khác nhau nhá
đây ví dụ mình sẽ cho hai cái hình này
anh em bây giờ ví dụ mình có nhiều hình
các bạn giữ cần cho là thích là cái hình
này để sau đó các bạn ở like đây các bạn
ví dụ mình căn trái song song với trái
với nhau lại đấy bọn đấy chứ nó sẽ dịch
sang trái thẳng hàng với cái này rất là
đẹp Nếu như các bạn có nhiều với bác
dùng á thì cái Online này cũng khá là
hay đấy tiếp theo mình sẽ giới thiệu các
bạn cái thẻ farmer farmer này thì các
bạn có thể nhưng xét cái fashion tức là
thay vì các bạn gõ trực tiếp thì bạn sẽ
nhập cái phân xưởng ở đây các bạn ví dụ
mình chọn cái hòm xong thì nạn thế nhá
thì gọi cho Chọn từng cái tổng đây đấy
là cái inspection the game is for để bị
rất ít dục cái file em về cũng dùng khá
là nhiều nhất sau này mình sẽ giới thiệu
các bạn cái phần đi filename này Nói
chung là cái thẻ Fortuner này cũng ít
dụng không dùng nhiều lắm nhưng mà cái
phông nền đặc biệt chú ý cho mình là cái
calculation of xin nhá các là chú nhá Nó
sẽ có hai cái chế độ mà mình hay dùng là
Automatic và men luộc kẻ Automatic là gì
Nếu như các bạn chọn cái ô tô
ở đây khi gọi rõ rệt các bạn sẽ bằng này
ví dụ với ô này nhá Có cộng thì các bạn
cậu ấy ôm này đấy thì nó sẽ ra là đây
mình sẽ đổi dễ gọn vào hôm mà mình sẽ
đổi vé số nó sẽ là 99 đúng không cái này
là vé số này nó sẽ ra 99 đúng không ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ vào cái Fortuner nhá thì
nó sẽ nổi mặc định để ví dụ khi ô này
mình sẽ đổi thành nhận cái ô Ví dụ nếu
không nhiên chính là mình đổi thành ngay
nhá thì cái kết quả đây nó sẽ tự động
tăng lên thành 11 đúng 0902 Cộng 11 mà
đấy nhưng mà khi mà cái calculation of
xin các bạn chọn men rùa đây nhá Đấy có
nhìn đây này Nó đang thích cái vào cái
chữ men lùa nữa nếu những bạn đổi cái số
này Ví dụ mình đổi là mười là Hạnh này
nhá thì cái công thức này nó không tự
động cập nhật để con theo đây ví dụ là
ba thế cái công thức này nó không tự
động cập nhật đấy Cái này Cho nên muốn
cầm ra đấy thì đoạn tích lũy vào đây có
bạn enter thì nó mới cập nhật mới tại
lại thì thông thường những cái
calculation of Shinee các bạn lên để chế
độ Automatic là tốt nhất các bạn hạn chế
để cái men luôn
Ừ ok tiếp theo là mình sẽ vào cái vợ thẻ
đây ta cái thẻ visa để dùng rất là nhiều
khi quan xử lý dữ liệu thì thứ nhất là
gì nó có thể lấy được dữ liệu ở bên
ngoài ví dụ từ web này từ cái tách file
đấy hoặc ở đây là những cái thành phần
khá là nâng cao rồi sau này mình sẽ giới
thiệu Xong cho các bạn nhá Đây là cái
phép này tức là mình sẽ cập nhật tất cả
cái phần sắp xếp lại cũng khá là hay để
sau này mình sẽ dùng sắp xếp khá nhiều
phim tơ đây ví dụ phân tích về đây nhá
qua chọn filter đấy bạn thấy cho toàn bộ
các Cái ô này đã có filter các bạn sẽ
tích vào đây này Ví dụ mình chọn là gì
cho bạn bỏ đi chọn cái kết một thôi Các
bạn bấm ok thì như vậy nó sẽ lọc lại ở
đây nó chỉ có tiết 1 đấy là cái filter
cũng khá là hai ví dụ Bình chrey đi
Dù sau này để mình cho học s Exciter này
cái tactical lầm đấy nhá nhiều cái rất
là hay trong này mình sẽ giới thiệu Xong
cho các bạn này cái thẻ review cái thẻ
review thì nó sẽ có một cái gì thứ nhất
là cái comment đấy ví dụ comment ở đây
nhá các bạn sẽ lưu comment ở đây ví dụ
các bạn để bạn xóa đây đầu tiên đây là
cái tên máy tính để mặc định ví dụ mình
đi đại diện ví dụ qua mệt này cô em mệt
đây là cái ghi chú thôi Cái Comment này
Kobe thay hạn thế nhá OB Thay đại khắc
ghi chú như thế nào người cạnh chó vào
đây Đấy thì nó sẽ hiện ghi chú bạn nhớ
được phải có ạ Có thể đi lấy cái comment
Ghi chú đi đấy thì ngoài ra mình hay
dùng ở cây phần dưỡng cái Texas và tốt
Facebook Tức là mình liên quan đến cái
phần bản vẽ file Ví dụ như mình có một
số thông tin mình không muốn cho người
khác xoay chỉnh sửa thì mình sẽ dùng cái
chức năng Cuốn sách này đây thì trong
treeview thì mình chú ý
Ừ rồi comment nữa Tiếp theo là cái thẻ
view thẻ vip Mình cũng khá là hay dùng
bây giờ cái view này cái loa mờ là cái
mặc định cái phái sao rồi mở lên đó là
leb đúng không các bạn mà tích chọn cái
chết Black review lại thì nó sẽ hiển thị
cái file này dưới dạng in ấn rồi bạn
thấy cho như vậy cái file của mình đang
ở hai trang Các bạn nhìn thấy game sọc
xanh ở đây là hai trang này đây nếu như
quả tích bằng cái phép leo ấy thì nó sẽ
hiển thị dưới dạng miệng dưới dạng một
cái tờ giấy giống như kiểu giấy A4 của
mình lại cái trang in đấy còn đấy cho đó
là ở hai Trang đúng không trang 1 đến
thứ năm thôi mà tranh ở đây là thứ Sáu ở
đó còn các bạn chọn Cát Tường lưu đã
chọn tùy chỉnh nhá Thông thường thì mình
hay để lau mờ còn cái sông này á ví dụ
đây cái sâu Phong đơn đó là hiện nay nếu
bạn bỏ chọn Ở đây còn thấy cái for mất
đi rồi đấy thì các bạn chú ý nhất nếu
bạn không thấy cái Phong nơi thì bạn vào
cái thẻ Như Quán Trọ sâu phong l Đây này
cái thứ biết like đây là gì Nếu như các
bạn bỏ chọn đây nhá thì tất cả các đường
viền để hiển thị các cái ô khác nhau
à còn hiện ở đây nữa lại cái hết đình
các bạn thích rồi đây thì nó sẽ không
còn cái tiêu đề nữa nhá Mình thích mà
hết tinh thì nó sẽ chọn việc tự thì nó
hiện cái tiêu đề cột và hàng ở đó lại
cái Dung là mình sẽ phóng to thu nhỏ cái
lưu Windows thì liên quan đến việc mở
nhiều wifi hoặc nhiều sheet excel cái
Philippines khá là hay liên quan đến cố
định tiêu đề nhé chẳng hạn như nếu như
mà cái tiêu đề ở hàng thứ hai là mình
muốn cố định tôi là phim mình dịch xuống
ấy thì cái hàng thứ hai nó không bị dịch
theo đúng không Thì họ sẽ tích và cái
hàng thứ ba sau đó có dọn phim Pain và
các bạn chọn cái đầu tiên này phi Bên
đấy bây giờ có lăn chuột xuống này bạn
thấy cho thì cái hàng thứ hai nó luôn
luôn hiện ở đây nó không bị trôi đi đấy
đấy là cái chức năng pin khá là hay mình
lại infiniband đẩy cái thần view nó như
thế thôi nhá xanh cái phần thép này cái
thép Vậy thì thông thường thì mình hay
nép mình dùng cái việc mà mình gõ cái
công thức đợi thì toàn và ghép các bạn
thích của thép ở đây này
Ừ thì nó sẽ hiện cái cửa sổ hét nhé Thì
tùy cái phiên bản khác nhau Ví dụ mình
muốn xem là cái hàm xong nó như thế nào
thì bạn gõ xong rồi đấy cậu enter đấy
thì nó sẽ hiện 1 số cái kết quả đây thì
mặc định Thông thường thì người ta hay
tìm cái săm phân xưởng ở đây nhất đúng
không Samsung phân xưởng tiếng Anh là
hàng có tính mở lại thì nó sẽ giới thiệu
cho bạn cách sử dụng của cái hòm xong
này Đấy nó còn có video coi đây để con
dùng nhất Rất là hay Nếu như các bạn là
không biết cách sử dụng các hành với bạn
vào đây theo dõi nhé Ok như vậy mình đã
giới thiệu xong các cái thẻ trên này rồi
nhá Còn cái trên này là diện trên này nó
gọi là các thần Michael Excel tool để
rất là một suối công cụ hay dùng thì nó
sẽ để trên mạng ví dụ các bạn chuyển cái
thẻ nào các bạn chuyển bất cứ cái thẻ
nào ấy thì cái cuốc setool3 này nó luôn
luôn cố định như thế này Đấy nó không hề
thay đổi đúng không phải ví dụ mình ăn
đu nhá tìm cái ăn đu mình hay dùng thì
mình sẽ thích ở đây thì mình sẽ ăn đu
các bước vừa xong đấy bước vào xong đang
là cái những cái kết nghe vì abdul thì
nó sẽ
ở đây nè đây ở đây là cái lum cũng hay
dùng để thì nó sẽ hiện ở đây Đây là cái
đĩa Thế là mình sẽ lưu file thì nó cũng
hay dùng gỡ tích ở đây Đây là cái quy
tắc setool3 tiếp theo là ở dưới này nhé
cạn túi ở dưới này nó có một số các
thành phần Đây là cái phóng to thu nhỏ
Các bạn có thể tích mà cái dấu cộng này
để còn thấy cho cái này nó sẽ to ra hoặc
bạn diện bạn tích vào cái cái nút đây
này có bạn giữ cho trái bạn kéo lại thì
họ sẽ phóng to Có ạ sang trái là thu nhỏ
vậy sang phải là phóng to đấy thì thông
thường mình hay để là một trăm phần trăm
đúng không Đây nó có một số cái phím tắt
để lo mờ này Đây là Tết me và cái page
Break preview đại tướng được 3 cái chức
năng ở trên này thôi ngoài ra thì các
bạn Thúy nhất cho mình ở đây là cái
thanh trạng thái là spa Đây là cái vùng
này bây giờ ví dụ khi các bạn Bun đ2ô
này nhá Đấy bạn thấy chứ thì nó sẽ hiện
một số thông tin là tổng của hai ôm mình
Bôi đen lúc nãy là 16 này cao Đấy Thế là
có hai cái ôm mình bôi và trung bình là
8 đấy các bạn có thể lấy được phải
các bạn thêm các cái hành tương ứng Ví
dụ mình chọn là minimart lại mắc thêm
nữa để qua sự tích vào ô bất kỳ để mình
thoát ra còn thấy cho Đấy nó sẽ hiện cái
điện Min và mắc viên nhỏ nhất là 3 và
mắc là 13 đúng không ạ Nếu như các bạn
muốn bỏ cái thông tin nào ấy thì bạn
nhấn phải các bạn lại thích vào đây đâu
Ví dụ mình bỏ Mini mình để bác thôi Chả
thế đấy thì nó mất Min rồi nó chỉ cần
mắt thôi Đây là cái Thanh cái thứ ba
cũng rất là hay dùng trong trường hợp
mình Bôi đen nhanh lên ví dụ mình bol4
ngôn này thì mình biết là diện cao bằng
4 tấc là mình lựa chọn 40 ô lại Ví dụ
mình Bôi đen 32 ôn này thì mặc dù các
bạn là bốn ông á Nhưng mà cao ở đây nó
bằng 3 tức là gì ạ một ô đang rỗng không
có giá trị đúng không ạ Và Các trung
bình ở đây bản chất là trung bình bao
thôi nhưng nếu nào rỗi thì nó chứ không
tính vào đây Đấy trung bình là trung
bình của ba u đến cũng đến có bao lâu
thôi bác là 13 và tổng của bao này là 26
đấy Cái tên thứ ba này khá là quan trọng
Đấy Ok cuối cùng là mình sẽ vào cái phần
câu hỏi cho cái video của cái
Cả ngày hôm nay câu hỏi thứ nhất là gì
Có thể thêm các công cụ khác và phải tan
truy cập nhanh không là cách cắt và may
Quick access toolbar này đây nhỉ Cho mở
cái xe gọi xe mà nơi này các máy quét
shuba tốt là mình có thể thêm các cái
chức năng vào đây không lại ví dụ các
chức năng là gì Ví dụ cái tăng giữa là
mình hay dùng hạn thế nhá hoặc là gì cái
tô đậm in nghiêng hoặc là gì đấy hoặc là
cái phần trăm mà mình hay dùng ấy thì
mình sẽ kéo lên đây hoặc là cái mất đây
tìm mình muốn kéo cái gì đến nay có được
hay không đây là câu hỏi số 1 nhé câu
hỏi số 2 là mình có thể thay đổi với
Phong 2 cỡ chữ mặc định khi tạo một file
mới hay không khi các bạn tạo một cái
file mới nhá Thì cái mặc định của nó là
cái calibri và cái phong là 11 này thì
bây giờ mình muốn thì mình có tại một
cái mặt mịn khác ví dụ là có chữ 14 và
cái phong là Arirang để hạn chế hoặc là
tham như Roman hạn thế nhé Mình muốn mặc
định thì mình có làm được hay không thì
đấy là hai cái câu hỏi cho các bạn nhé
các bạn hãy comment Đấy phần trả lời ở
phía dưới
Ừ Ok như vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học
ngày hôm nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã
theo dõi các bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập
nhật video mới nhất của gà cũng như chia
sẻ để giúp mọi người cùng học Excel nhé
Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại ở